quel est le nom de la version italienne
de tpm p aa
on a mûri ce mot mais notre cas les
ennemis au poste
ces spams daddy ou des bandits des
tocards dos conor conoco nord
alors ok mais là aussi rien on verra
mais annoncé en date
vous êtes bon on s'en va là petit
absolument d'attirer bon et donc tous
pas mon poste à 8 ans a été exportée
dans pas mal de balles réelles non
l'italie exporté au liban en italie et
lien un intérêt apparemment de
l'allemagne pour une déclinaison en
quotidienne à baghdatis ça veut dire en
gros les traînards des trains de retard
mais celle là bas aussi il met en valeur
les collections clandestine en tunisie
le pays de cyril mais voilà donc si
lille un peu mais c'est son pays
d'origine
patrick gueuler mais je les ai
rencontrés là-bas ils sont super ça
paraît bref il est super jolie c'est un
copié collé voilà mais confie prison
papilles les droits il est bien en
italie le mec qui remplace la jetta
saura y jouer et j'ai donc des images
mais là bas c'est pas un animateur
ils sont tous à west ham ont remplacé
celles pour moi deux war 3 2 1
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et longtemps tour d'espagne
alors là la première émission italie a
fait 700 sont 15 me elle varie
aujourd'hui c'est en deuxième partie de
soirée
ça marche ou pas ça oui franchement ça
marche bien d'accord oui je vous en
parle